hi I'm Ashlyn Harris and I'm Ali Krieger
and we play for the US Women's National
Team and the Orlando pride and we are
here to take the relationship let's see
who knows each other better
[Music]
okay so first our birthday I'll start
it's July 28th and 1984 gee we really
have to save the date it's your birthday
like summer 1995 okay
age 34 like soon to be 35 yeah 33 I'm
gonna be a 34 dr. your sign I don't know
I like I don't know I don't have them
Ariane Aries
no what are you we're gonna skip that
one
your middle name is Michelle your middle
name is Blair parents named Kenny Kay
and good old Devers Mike and Tammy names
of the siblings hi J Krieger the name of
the of your first pet Hannah is yours
Momo
oh no sorry peaches Wow I know the name
of our current pet Walter we have a dog
eating name illusion she's a kink or
some massive - 110 pound okay your
favorite movie I'm trying to blink
double jeopardy yours is a musical on
with walk-behind no no that's like a top
three though totally top three I would
say probably avatar yeah
avatar Point Break okay favorite TV show
you like pose yeah you're right I love
pose well your favorite show right now
is Handmaid's Tale
you're obsessed you want yeah your
favorite part
well this has to be so easy
lots of magazines yeah your favorite
book is um she has it a quote on this
her side the little pandas if that's the
color Luna a little friend
what good your favorite brand I didn't
go so many I'm probably Gucci know what
Oh Ambrose sorry
um girl your favorite brands Nike
favorite food
she loves Mexican cuisine yeah mmm-hmm
your favorite food my mac and cheese yes
my grandma's good
well we're killing this it's supposed to
get hard what is it release favorite
food she will not eat what is that weird
slimy looking thing called do it don't
tell me it's big purple the purple what
does that thing called eggplant yes you
will not touch eggplant look your least
favorite food
you're a texture person picture so like
I can yeah I can't
yeah I can't really links with scallop
or an octopus oh good I can't your
preferred pizza topping Oh yours is
pepperoni all day mmm-hmm I think you
like margarita pizza so it's like very
simple oh yeah you're right your
favorite soda club soda
you're wrong you have a good cup okay
there's my two things I drink on a daily
basis topo Chico which is right
sparkling water club soda for Mexican
cool it right I keep it in the family
your favorite alcoholic drink all of the
above I'm just kidding she loves wine
Brown don't look at mine you gotta say
it yeah like hazel right you grew up a
yes you grew up in Satellite Beach you
know it you weren't a dog person until I
think Logan really until I got my dog I
don't like that now you like love yeah
she's very very true you're definitely a
dog so personally I do not deal with
cats no not really
your best friend is Liz mum Leigh your
best friend as well you feel really
awesome I do
liz claiborne oh you know it those are
my homies Allie takes her coffee on a
bougie day you like an iced vanilla
latte with oat milk yeah if you're basic
she'll be like okay I'll take a black
would room for cream yeah new love your
coffee just black but you would really
enjoy a nitro cold Braille I want him to
start shaking and cry on my skin Oh
favorite season I know this do love fall
yeah obsess anything but I like fall cuz
I spent a lot I mean all day yeah I'm a
beach girl I would say you like to see
me yeah you always are good good that
one in my budget yeah I am your dream
job probably be a creative director for
a big-time brand yeah or do acting or
something like that well you just know
me yeah I would say your dream job would
be some type of breaking barriers like
in the men's sports world being on
camera but like a seat at the table like
the main bhi ash yeah you know mmm
or like hosting your own TV show we're
having your own for all I don't know
probably all they love yeah did I nail
it or mice or that look I would love it
broadcasting but I also would love on my
worst job you've never really I really
work with your favorite sports your
favorite sports team anything and
everything easy yeah shout out to all my
DC Danby teams yeah but your favorite
soccer team is Chelsea yeah through and
through
cool favorite hockey is capped always
they say gnats and baseball yeah at
Oriole is just because I grew up going
to the game well it has to be answering
for you better what about my phone what
seems besides like Orlando Magic in
Orlando city I'd you're kind of just
like whatever like you're not yeah
you're not really like so hard cause I
mean like except for UNC basketball oh
and your song yeah yeah so it's yeah
Carolina everything I don't think you
have any I took things all dirty
I'm a clean but I don't have you don't
have allergies you know your biggest
celebrity crush is it a guy or girl Wow
I mean I'll hit you know the f are like
random people on Instagram but I don't
really know
oh I had to I didn't David Beckham yeah
okay David Beckham I need to meet him
I'm obsessed with him okay his line Sam
hunt I know you so well
roll it once our role at three times
because that changed things I don't
think you can I definitely can't yeah
it's just a few if you know I can't or
not know you know name of their first
love Tyler L
my friends yeah Brent gave Brandt the
name of our favorite co-worker you would
say we well for sure
well now I wouldn't okay Megan Rapinoe
okay she's like psyche that yeah and
what would you say you'd say the same
thing
no as I said said oh yeah yeah okay
you're right-handed
yes and your nickname Krieg's
yep you guys these we're killing it what
their parents jobs are or if they're
retired yeah teachers you're both your
parents mm-hmm
your mom works for the for Low's like
business sector mm-hmm and Mike is a he
works for the county but he's like in
charge of yours yep favorite school
subject yours is probably physical
education I feel like yours would be
like something weird you love to read
what is it what is it just hey PE o
you're smarter than that well not sure
okay good to know
least favorite school subject you
probably history yeah me too your
biggest fear probably snakes might be
around slowly
I hate okay your biggest fear me leaving
you oh girl no no all right what's your
biggest fear I don't know I'm probably
just dying alone
see I'm here for you yeah what year did
you graduate high school you graduated
and you in 2002 3 2003 yeah yeah what's
closer you need some credit
oh yeah you're right oh for you graduate
college in 2009 because you stayed in
you in 2007 whoa
Allie will absolutely not go camping and
unless it's cold we're in some remote
cottage with AC brain
they don't pity me outside yeah with a
few don't over salut and I'm tempurpedic
bed
you can't camp but you brother you know
like a I gonna be anytime okay oh yeah
your favorite ice cream flavor mint
chocolate chip you can do I think it's a
yes you like yours in a cup you like
yours in a cone yes
you know not like spicy food you don't
either I know she's not you're not
you're not vegan or vegetarian but you
won't eat meat off of only small things
you learn about your partner you prefer
ice cream cake yeah over anything
mm-hmm and you prefer cake which is
heavy you do not like your sucked in you
know I have you haven't I said I felt
like that's terrible your favorite
probably no will you say on Instagram
stories non-stop what is our edge you're
if you don't swear you're not us you're
not you don't touch only a left field if
I'm like really angry
you ain't honestly they're very or at
the roughs and the colors are really
what would you even say your favourite
swearword is you don't swear well do we
crush it or do we crush it you guys I
think we crushed it I got thirty forty
six point I want 44 points I won 46 oh I
know you better
well thank you guys for watching our
relationship quiz I came out on top so
she got a point or two ahead of me yeah
I watertight now yo I know you better
than you know me well uh so thanks for
watching yeah time from that was a blast
yeah watch us at the NWSL we play for
the Orlando pride yes y'all know we're
purple yeah come on board us go pride no
pride go us
you